i was interrupted in the last video by a
phone call i was actually expecting a
phone call from someone whose call i
wanted to take but that ended up being
one of those robocallers so anyway i was
on problem 163 let me just start it over
just so that i don't interrupt your
train of thought a fruit salad mixture
consists of apples peaches of gray and
grapes in the ratio of six to five to
two so the ratio of apples to peaches
to grapes
is equal to six
to five
to 2
by weight if 39 pounds of the mixture is
prepared the mixture includes how many
more pounds of apples
than grapes so they essentially want us
to figure out what the apples minus the
grapes
are equal to so we have 39 pounds so the
pounds of apples plus the
peaches plus the grapes that equals 39
pounds
and to do a ratio problem like this the
easiest way to say is well
the apples let's just define the apples
as being the number of pounds of apples
being six times some number x
if the apples are six times somewhere
some number x what are the peaches
well we know that the ratio of the
apples to the peaches are six to five so
the peaches are going to have to be five
times some number x by the same logic
the grapes are going to have to be
two times some number x and if you try
out you know the ratio of the apples to
the grapes is six x over two x which is
six to two which is 6 to 2. so it all
works out so let's use this information
to substitute back there and see what x
is equal to
so we get 6 x plus 5 x
plus 2 x is equal to 39
and that's what 6 plus 5 is 11 plus 2
is 13 13
x is equal to 39
x
is equal to 3
and so how many apples are there 6x are
18 apples
we don't have to figure out the peaches
but we can do it right fast there are 15
peaches and then there are
six grapes
and if you want to know how many more
apples there are than grapes 18 minus
six
18 minus 6 is equal to 12
actually these are all in pounds there
are 12 pounds more of apples than grapes
and that's choice
b
problem 164
luis has x more dollars than jim has
so l is equal to
gym plus x
and together they have a total of y
dollars so l plus j
is equal to y
which of the following represents the
number of dollars that jim has
so they want
jim
equal and they want in terms of x and y
so let's
let's take this and substitute and take
this l and substitute here so that we
have an equation that just has js x's
and y's in it so if l is equal to j plus
x we can substitute so we get
j
plus x instead of an l
plus j
is equal to y
right that is that just that
and you have 2
j
plus x is equal to y subtract x from
both sides
2 j is equal to y
minus x and we get j is equal to y minus
x
over 2
and that is choice a
problem 165. switch colors
5.
during a certain season a team won 80
percent of its first hundred games
so eighty percent of the first hundred
games and fifty percent of the remaining
fifty percent of the remaining games if
the team won seventy percent of its
games for the entire season
so they won seventy percent of total
seventy percent
of the total
of the total what was the total number
of games that the team played
okay so how do we figure out the the
total number of games that they played
it'll be a hundred plus remainder
right
so let's think of it this way if we
wanted to figure out the the total
percentage that they won we would want
the number that they won so how many
games did they win
they won
they won 80 percent of a hundred of
their first hundred games so that's 80
games
plus 50 percent of the remainder games
so plus 0.5 times the remainder
that's how many games they won now how
many games did they play well the total
number of games is going to be 100
plus whatever this remainder number of
games are that's their total number of
games and then the problem tells us that
this ratio the percent the total
percentage right this is all the games
they won divided by all the games they
played that that is equal to 0.7 or 70
percent
and let's see if we multiply both sides
of this equation by 100 plus r we get 80
plus 0.5
r is equal to 0.7 times 100 is equal to
plus 0.7 r
now let's subtract 70 from both sides
you get 10
plus 0.5
r is equal to 0.7 r
and then if we subtract 0.5 r from both
sides we get 10
is equal to 0.2 r
or r is equal to 10
over
0.2 right and ten over point two
point two is the same thing as one fifth
so this is ten times five so that's
equal to fifty
so the remainder games were fifty so
they're they're asking us what are they
asking us they wanna know the total
number of games the team played so it's
going to be the first hundred games plus
the remainder games so 100 plus 50 they
played 150 games which is choice
d
problem
we're on problem 166
of 30 applicants for a job 14 had at
least four years of experience so
experience greater than
four we have 14
i just make up notation as we go
of 30 applicants for a job 14 had at
least 4 years of experience 18 had
degrees so we say degrees
we have 18
and three had less than four years of
experience and did not have a degree
three
so
experience was less than four years
experience
and
no degree
and that is
three people
how many of the applicants had at least
four years of experience
and a degree
at least four years of experience and a
degree so let's see if we can if how we
can think about it there's 30 applicants
for a job
14 so let me draw our universe
so let's see if i did all of the
applicants
let me draw it like this
so that's the whole applicant universe
and that's 30
and we know that 14 had more than
four years of experience so let me do
that in this color
so this
this i guess attribute
let's try so 14
is roughly i'll make it look like
that so that's the 14
that have experience greater than four
years and that's 14 of them
and then 18 have a degree
right 18 have a degree and i'm assuming
that there's some
some overlap between the degrees and the
14 we don't know that for sure but let's
say that this point right here
i'll draw it by another
venn diagram another circle
so let's say that circle looks something
like that
so let's call this the degreed people
there's 18 of them in this whole circle
and then
they say that there are three people
with experience less than four and no
degrees so they're outside of both of
these circles so this right here
is three
right
okay now what are they asking i've
already forgotten that how many of the
applicants had at least four years
experience and a degree so they're
asking for
this intersection
right here
so there's one question we can answer
how many people what's the sum of of
this population the population that it
has
that has
more than four years of experience or a
degree right so let me circle what's
this sum right here this
and this
well it's going to be whatever is left
after you take out the three people who
have nothing right so that's going to be
27 people so 27 people have
let me write that down 27 people have at
least four years of experience or a
degree
now how can we relate that to the 14 and
18.
so what happens if we just add the 14
and the 18.
if we just add the 14 when we add when
we have the 14 we're going to count
these people once
right and then if we were to add that to
18 we would count these people twice
so if we wanted this number if we wanted
the number of people who are in this
circle or this circle what we want to do
is add the 14
to the 18
but then subtract out once the people
who are in this intersection right let's
call them b
that's a b i know you can't read it
let's say there are b people in that
intersection you'll subtract that out
once and i want you to i want that to
really make sense for you right if we
want to know the total number of people
in this circle and this circle combined
if we added the number of degrees to the
num when we say 18 people that's
including some people here and if we
were to add that to 14 people where once
again some of those 14 are here again
are these people so we just add 18 to 14
we're counting this twice so if we want
to know the exact the actual number in
this circle or this circle since we add
18 to 14 we count it twice we want to
subtract these people out once hopefully
that makes sense but anyway now we're
ready to solve we get 27 is equal to 14
plus 18 is equal to 32
minus b
and you can we can you know we can 27
from both sides you get 0 is equal to 5
minus b add b to both sides you get b is
equal to 5.
and that is
that is choice e
see in the next video